-Thank you so much for being
in studio, for being here.
-Nah, when I got the offer...
-Yeah.
-...I said, especially MLK Day,
I'm gonna come here in person
to be with you.
-Thank you for that.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Means a lot.
Thank you.
-Thank you, thank you.
-I appreciate that.
I want to get into
"Da 5 Bloods."
You know I loved it.
-Thank you very much.
Second time for "Da 5 Bloods,"
appreciate it.
-Yeah, that's right.
I want to talk to you about
a project I heard is going to be
your next project.
-Right.
-Stop me if I'm wrong.
It's a musical, right?
Okay?
You're doing a musical,
and it's a musical about Viagra.
-True story.
[ Laughter ]
And I'd like to say, though,
if God willing,
and the creek doesn't rise.
But I want to give you
another piece of information
about the film referred to,
Brother Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
This is gonna be
the hardest film I ever made.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
I had to think of all --
-Had to think of all of it --
-It's gonna be the hardest film
I ever made!
[ Laughter ]
Stop the show! Stop the show!
-Stop the show!
Go to commercial!
-I want to talk about
your other film,
the one that you came out
before, "Da 5 Bloods."
-Yes.
-It is on every list
for award buzz.
And well-deserved.
I loved it. And I actually
told you, my dad was in Vietnam,
and I had him --
-You told me that.
-Dude, he loved it, as well.
I just love that all these guys
and girls have stories to tell
that fought in Vietnam.
-Well, again, thank you for
having me today, on MLK Day.
The black soldiers in Vietnam
did not know
till two or three days later
that Dr. King
had been assassinated.
And, uh...
They learned
through Hanoi Hannah...
-Yeah.
-...who was the voice
of the Viet Cong.
Hanoi Hannah
told the black soldiers,
"Why are you fighting for a
country that does not love you?
Why are you fighting
for this country
when your brothers and sisters
are burning
a hundred cities in America?"
And that's documented.
And to continue this,
April 4, 1968,
I was 11 years old.
11 years old,
sitting on my stoop --
Not porch!
In Brooklyn, it's stoops.
-Yep, that's right.
-Stoops!
I hear a woman screaming.
And as the voice gets closer,
I recognize,
it's my mother's voice.
And she's screaming --
I swear on her grave --
She's screaming,
"They killed Dr. King!
They killed Dr. King!
They killed Dr. King!"
And an argument can be made that
Dr. King was assassinated
not because of
the Civil Rights Movement
but because he was one of
the first people, vocally,
out front, to say the war
in Vietnam was immoral.
-That scene in the movie
is so poignant
because they're hearing this
over the radio.
-That's where the majority
of the black troops --
Would also like to say, in the
latest stage of the Vietnam War,
black soldiers, the Bloods,
they made up a third
of the fighting forces.
Yet African-Americans
are only 10% of the population
of the United States of America.
Only 10% of the population
but yet we were third
of the fighting force
in Vietnam.
Facts.
Facts, undisputable.
-I'm glad you're
getting it out there,
because these stories
need to be heard.
-Yeah, there's so many stories.
And also, over the years,
thank you for having me
on your show,
letting me reach your audience,
love.
The Roots, love you guys.
The Knicks are good this year.
Watch me.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show everyone
a clip from the movie.
Here is a scene
from "Da 5 Bloods."
Take a look at this.
-Black G.I.
In Memphis, Tennessee,
a white man assassinate
Dr. Martin Luther King.
Dr. King also opposed
the U.S. War in Vietnam.
Black G.I., your government
sent 600,000 troops
to crush the rebellion.
Your soul sister
and soul brothers
are enraged in over 122 cities.
They kill them.
Why you fight against us?
So far away
from where you are needed.
[ Applause ]
-Spike Lee, everybody,
the one and only!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know I love you, man.
Thank you so much
for being here in studio.
-The house!
-Spike Lee.
"Da 5 Bloods"
is streaming now on Netflix.